now here's the problem here's the
problem this this situation here
this is not this the numbers don't have
the same base
but we can make them have the same base
okay how are we going to do it
okay um you've got twos there right
you can do it with those alley you've
got an idea times everything by two
okay now pause first idea first idea
like when you've got fractions hold on
to pair
if you had something like this uh i'm
just trying to think of examples right
yeah i know you know but we've got to
get there together just because you know
it doesn't mean
well we need to we need to finish that
idea first okay now here
you can multiply everything by two we
were just looking at these like last
week right what would happen when i
multiply both sides by two
you get x and then you get eight what's
two times a quarter two times a quarter
it's a half yeah
yeah well done okay good so there you go
i could do that
now this is important because this is
why multiplying by two here
not such a good idea we could do it here
but you absolutely cannot do it here can
anyone see why
um
see this thing i just circled in red
what is that we gave it a name
right we have we spent like half a
topping
this thing's an equation right it's an
equation
this is not an equation there's no equal
sign on this line here this isn't like
there's no x's or anything like that
yeah it's not an equation you can't just
multiply things by whatever number you
like unless it's an equation
because it's a balanced thing you can do
it to both sides that's fine there are
no
sides to this there's just numbers okay
so don't multiply
by two you'll change it to a completely
different thing okay
it was a good idea but for a different
kind of problem excuse me
another suggestion nathan had his hand
up first um simplify it
how would you simplify it the idea is to
simplify how we're going to do it
um make it like the base number one
times two
and then you can simplify that okay
nathan your suggestion was one times two
right yeah one times two
and then um
why not it doesn't count okay
so here fine i'll let you here we go um
just like in an equation you have to
find
the common thing so in that you would
make the two or four and then half the
six to make it a three so if you
whoa whoa okay oh i think you're on to
something but slow down
slow down you want you want something in
common
now hold on this is this is we're on the
right track here okay
getting things in common is one of the
key ways things work together for
instance
if i gave you this right you got
fractions and
here we want the same base but here we
don't want the same base we want the
same
denominator right so we say common
denominator and then they can work what
would we do in this case
we'd make that six three over six
you'd make that two over six and then
you get the answer
cool okay now we're going to do
something very similar to pair tell me
again
but slower this time
um you're gonna like you're gonna make
the two into a four
by changing the the six into a three
because you have to
simplify it if you're gonna matter
are you saying that to the power of six
is the same as
is that what you're suggesting okay now
i'm curious
who thinks who thinks that that's true
like this is actually very very
important
is 2 to the 6 equal to
4 cubed question mark
is it i'm not sure
how how could you tell it's good well
you could put it in a calculator
that would do it it's not right pretty
sure that's 64.
right this is also so actually this was
is that
always true is it always true
for example for example it depends um
let's just let's just try it okay
what if i had five nerd pawn
yeah five okay five to the power of six
right is that the same
as ten to the power of three
is it the same okay because what i did
was you know from here to here
these numbers this number got twice as
big so this one got
half the size and i'm trying to do the
same thing here does it work
no no but that's not the case are you
sure yes it does yes it does
but you see here's the thing right well
you have to take an approach
does it does it yes it does it
does
okay let's take this guy right he's five
times five
times five times five times five
times five uh
3125 uh
15 000. 626
that's just a thousand it doesn't work
okay now
here's the thing okay the reason why i'm
going after this
because we can actually take your
approach for this question right
but i'm interested in giving an approach
that will always work not just one that
occasionally it coincidentally works but
most of the time
it's a bad way to go okay so here's what
we'll do
let's just try that seeing as we just
did show that it works
for this one in particular okay let's go
after it and then we'll look at an
example
it does and see what else we can do if
this will work now what do i do
add them this is two numbers with the
same
base
that works four to the power of six
okay
4 to the hmm of 3 times 4 to the power 3
and then you go equals
4 to the power of 3 plus 3 do you if you
write that in
is that like an extra mark so you don't
have to oh sir
hold on hold on the answer your question
is
no it's not an extra mark but i'm
putting it into you so you know what's
going on
right you know have you ever had that
experience where you go back to working
later on you're like i don't know why
this isn't
just so that's what i show you yeah
that's another reason why
this shows you understand okay